حراره هذا الفرن تسهر صخور الناريه وتتحول
فيه خامات الحديد الى فلان العمال في
افران الشهر التابعه لمصنع زابوجيستال
امام نار لا تطفى مشتعله على مدار 24 ساعه
من المستحيل ايقافه حتى في حال حدوث هجوم
على المدينه نظرا لان الفرن يعمل باستمرار
فلا يمكننا مغادره موقعنا يجب ان يكون
لدينا حد ادنى من الاشخاص يبقون هنا ويجب
توفير الحمايه لهم بشكل صحيح عندما تدوي
صفاره الانذار علينا ارتداء السترات
الواقيه من الرصاص
قبل الحرب كان يعمل فيستال اكثر من عشره
الاف موظف وبسبب نقص المواد الخام يعمل
المصنع بنسبه 50% من اجمالي طاقته
الانتاجيه
تم ايقاف عدد كبير من العمال بشكل مؤقت
انضم عشره بالمئه من موظفي الى صفوف الجيش
الاوكراني
وبالرغم من الصعوبات يحافظ العمال
والموظفون على تفاؤلهم
لطالما كانت الاجواء هنا وطنيه وما زالت
حتى الان في الواقع فريقنا اكثر اتحادا
ويتعين على اولئك الذين بقوا ان يعملوا
بجهد اكبر
معنوياتنا هي عاليه ونحن جميعا نتطلع الى
النصر
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا يعد الحفاظ على نشاط
قطاع التعدين امرا حيويا قطاع قرر رغم
صعوباته مساعده البلاد في ايام الحرب
اذا كان علينا التحدث عن دعمنا للجيش فنحن
نقدم سترات وخوذات واقيه من الرصاص
كما نقدم لكل جندي من عشره معدات حمايه
اضافه الى كل ذلك
نوفر حول 150 ملجا محصنا تحت الارض
ملاجئ مثل هذه تم تصنيعها للخنادق لحمايه
الجنود في الميدان وفي جبهات القتال يساعد
القطاع الصناعي القطاع العسكري في هذه
الحرب وكل شهر يمضي دليل على ان اهميه
العامل في هذا المصنع لا تقل عن اهميه
الجند في خط المعركه